uh you mentioned the next version of
llama what can you say about the next
version of llama what what can you say
about like what uh what were you working
on in terms of release in terms of the
vision for that well a lot of what we're
doing is taking the first version which
was primarily you know this research
version and trying to now build a
version
that has
all of the latest state-of-the-art
safety precautions built in
um and and we're
um we're using some more data to train
it from across our services but
but a lot of the the work that we're
doing internally is really just focused
on making sure that this is
um you know as
aligned and responsible as possible and
you know we're building a lot of our own
you know we're talking about kind of the
open source infrastructure but you know
the the main thing that we focus on
building here you know a lot of product
experiences to help people connect and
express themselves so you know we're
gonna I've talked about a bunch of this
stuff but um and you'll have an
assistant that you can talk to in
WhatsApp
um you know I think I I think in the
future every Creator will will have kind
of an AI agent that can kind of act on
their behalf that their fans can talk to
I I want to get to the point where every
small business basically has an AI agent
that people can talk to for you know to
do Commerce and customer support and
things like that so they're going to be
all these different things and
llama or the language model underlying
this is is basically going to be the
engine that powers that the reason to
open source it is that um as we did with
um with the the first version is that it
uh
basically it unlocks a lot of innovation
in the ecosystem will make our products
better as well and also gives us a lot
of valuable feedback on security and
safety which is important for making
this good but yeah I mean the the work
that we're doing to advance the
infrastructure it's um it's basically at
this point taking it Beyond a research
project into something which is ready to
be kind of core infrastructure not only
for our own products but
um you know hopefully for for a lot of
other things out there too do you think
the Llama Or the language model
underlying that version two will be open
sourced
you're you have internal debate around
that the pros and cons and so on this is
I mean we were talking about the debates
that we have internally and I think
um
I think the question is how to do it
right I mean it's I think we
you know we we did the research license
for V1 and and I think the the big thing
that we're that we're thinking about is
is basically like what's the what's the
right the right way so there was a leak
that happened I don't know if you can
comment on it for V1 you know we
released it as a research project
um for researchers to be able to use but
in doing so we put it out there so
um you know we were very clear that
anyone who uses the the code and the
weights doesn't have a commercial
license to put into products and we've
we've generally seen people respect that
right it's like you don't have any
reputable companies that are basically
trying to put this into into
um their commercial products but but
yeah but by sharing it with you know so
many researchers it's it's you know yeah
it did leave the building but uh what
have you learned from that process that
you might be able to apply to V2 about
how to release it safely effectively uh
if if you release it yeah well I mean I
think a lot of the feedback like I said
is just around you know different things
around you know how do you fine-tune
models to make them more aligned and
safer and you see all the different data
recipes that
um you know you mentioned a lot of
different
projects that are based on this I mean
there's one Berkeley there's you know
it's just like all over and um
and
people have tried a lot of different
things and we've tried a bunch of stuff
internally so kind of where we're we're
making progress here but also we're able
to learn from some of the best ideas in
the community and you know I think it
you know we want to just continue
continue pushing that forward but so
like but I don't have any news to
announce um if that's if that's what
you're you're asking I mean this is a a
thing that
were uh
we're still we're still kind of you know
actively working through the the right
way to move forward here the details of
the secret sauce are still being
developed I see uh can you comment on
what do you think of uh the thing that
worked for GPT which is the
reinforcement learning with human
feedback so doing this alignment process
do you find it interesting and as part
of that let me ask because I talked to
Jana lacun before talking to you today
he asked me to ask or suggested that I
ask do you think
llm fine tuning will need to be
crowdsourced Wikipedia Style
so crowdsourcing so this kind of idea of
how to integrate the human in the
fine-tuning of these Foundation models
yeah I think that's a really interesting
idea that I've talked to Jan about a
bunch
um
and
we're talking about
how do you basically train these models
to be as as safe and aligned and
responsible as possible and you know
different groups out there who are doing
development
test different data recipes in fine
tuning but this idea that you you just
mentioned is
that at the end of the day
instead of having kind of one group
fine-tune some stuff and another group
you know produce a different fine-tuning
recipe and then
us trying to figure out which one we
think works best to produce the most
aligned model
um
I I do think that
it would be nice if you could get to a
point where you had a Wikipedia style
collaborative
way for a kind of a broader Community to
um to to fine-tune it as well now
there's a lot of challenges in that both
from an infrastructure and like uh
Community Management and product
perspective about how you do that so I I
haven't worked that out yet
um but as an idea I think it's it's
quite compelling and I think it it goes
well with the ethos of open sourcing the
technology is also finding a way to have
a kind of Community Driven
um
a Community Driven training of it
um but I think there are a lot of
questions on this in general these this
these questions around what's the the
best way to produce aligned AI models
it's very much a research area and it's
one that I think we will need to make as
much progress on as the kind of core
intelligence capability of the of the um
the models themselves well I just did a
conversation with Jimmy Wales the
founder of Wikipedia and to me Wikipedia
is one of the greatest websites ever
created
and it's a kind of a miracle that it
works and I think it has to do with
something that you mentioned which is
community you have a small community of
editors
that somehow work together well and they
they handle very controversial
topics and they handle it
with balance and with Grace despite sort
of the attacks that will often happen a
lot of the time I mean it's not it's it
has issues just like any other human
system but yes I mean the balance is I
mean it's a it's amazing what they've
been able to achieve but it's also not
perfect and I think that that's
um there's still a lot of challenges
right it's uh the more controversial the
topic the more the more difficult uh the
uh
the journey towards quote-unquote truth
or knowledge or wisdom that Wikipedia
tries to capture in the same way AI
models will need to
be able to generate those same things
truth knowledge and wisdom and how do
you align those models that they
generate
um something that uh is closest to truth
there's these concerns about
misinformation all this kind of stuff
that nobody can Define
and this is something that we together
as a human species have to Define like
what is truth and how to help AI systems
generate that one of the things language
models do really well is generate
convincing sounding things that can be
completely wrong
and so how do you align it
uh to be less wrong
and part of that is the training and
part of that is the alignment and
however you do the alignment stage and
just like you said it's a very new and a
very open research problem
yeah and I think that there's also
a lot of questions about whether the
current architecture for llms
as you continue scaling it what happens
um I mean a lot of the a lot of what's
been exciting in the last year
is that there's there's clearly a
qualitative breakthrough where you know
with with some of the GPT models that
opened I put out and and that others
have been able to do as well
I I think it reached a kind of level of
quality where people like wow this is
this feels different and
um
and like it's going to be able to be the
foundation for building a lot of awesome
products and experiences and value but I
think the other realization that people
have is wow we just made a breakthrough
[Music]
um
if there are other breakthroughs quickly
then I think that there's the sense that
maybe where we're closer to general
intelligence but I think that that idea
is predicated on the idea that I think
people believe that there's still
generally a bunch of additional
breakthroughs to make and that it's um
we just don't know
how long it's going to take to get there
and you know one view that some people
have
um this doesn't tend to be my view as
much is that simply
scaling the current llms and you know
getting to higher parameter count models
by itself we'll we'll get to something
that is closer to
um to to general intelligence but
um I don't know I tend to think that
there's probably more more um
fundamental steps that need to be taken
along the way there but still the leaves
taken
with this extra alignment step is quite
incredible quite surprising to to a lot
of folks and on top of that
when you start to have hundreds of
millions of people potentially using a
product that integrates that
you can start to see civilization
transforming effects before you achieve
super quote-unquote super intelligence
it could be super transformative without
being a super intelligence
I mean I think that they're going to be
a lot of amazing products and value that
can be created with the current level of
Technology
um
to some degree
yeah I'm excited to
work on a lot of those products over the
next few years and I think it would just
create
a tremendous amount of whiplash if the
number of breakthroughs keeps like if if
they're keep on being stacked
breakthroughs because I think to some
degree industry in the world needs some
time to kind of build these
breakthroughs into the products and
experiences that we all use that we can
actually benefit from them
um
but
I don't know I think there's just a a
like an awesome amount of stuff to do
and I think about like all of the
I don't know small businesses or
individual entrepreneurs out there who
um now we're going to be able to you
know get help coding the things that
they need to go build things or
designing the things that they need or
um we'll be able to you know use these
models to be able to do customer support
for the people that they're that they're
serving you know over WhatsApp without
having to you know I I think that that's
that's just gonna be I just think that
this is all going to be you know super
exciting it's going to create better
better experiences for people and just
unlock a ton of innovation and value